in guten zeiten noch sagen ja auf die
tube drücken konnte genau unsere richtig
menopause alle frauen richtig ein grund
und boden schreiben konnte
[Musik]
findet man nicht haben uns eine art
spiel ausgedacht wo wir uns gegenseitig
lieblingssätze aus der weltliteratur
oder aus büchern die wir gelesen haben
vorlesen aus dem weg mach dich
ungeschehen ich sehr schön da musste ich
spontan an filme denken ich wusste auch
in niefern außerdem weg macht dich
ungeschehen ich fange ich an zu weinen
aber mir gefällt er sagt auch ich finde
einfach sprachlich die variante zu einer
höflichen form von könnten sie sich
bitte verpassen wäre toll
der ganze saal sitzt voller klimakterium
und sowas gibts und sowas nennt sich
ferien
das ist erich kästner das wunderbare
gedicht an ein scheusal im abendkleid wo
er sich die ganze zeit darüber mokiert
wie unglaublich fürchterlich diese frau
aussieht in diesem abend klarheit man
liest es passt mit einer gewissen
nostalgie heutzutage und denkt so ja es
hat auch was das erfrischende sehr guten
zeiten noch na ja auf die tube drücken
konnte nun sind richtig menopause alle
frauen richtig in grund und boden
schreiben konnte
ich konnte ihm einmal auch hier den
reihen von key materien und ferien so
was gefällt mir
sie stand da eine siegerin in dem guten
streite den sie während der zeit ihres
lebens gegen die anfechtungen von seiten
ihrer lehrerinnen vernunft geführt hatte
wirklich winzig und beben vor
überzeugung eine kleine strafen der
begeisterte propheten das hört sich an
wie sibylle lewitscharoff mein gott das
bricht mir das herz das ist thomas mann
der letzte satz der bogen ich habe mir
die buddenbrooks ist zum schluss
gekommen dass ich mir nachher als eine
kleine strafende begeisterte propheten
das großartig wenn sie einem
durchschnittsmenschen seine lebenslüge
rauben dann nehmen sie ihm gleichzeitig
nicht das ist großartig das stimmt das
ist von mir aus der wildente von ok dies
auch von mir wenn sie einem
durchschnittsmenschen seine lebenslüge
rauben da nehmen sie ihm gleichzeitig
sein glück das ist großartig da besteht
ein ganz großer teil der weltliteratur
literatur macht klüger nicht immer aber
meistens gescheitert
weiter lesen
ende
[Musik]